may be out for more than just the summer
if a powerful teachers union gets its
way
union boss randy weingarten won't commit
to schools opening back up after the
cdc's latest guidance
we want schools to reopen and have a
safe and welcoming climate
in the fall delta threw us a real
curveball
and you know the lack of the
the herd immunity and
enough people being vaccinated and you
know
kids not being able to get vaccines
um 12 and under we're going to keep kids
safe
we're going to keep our members safe and
we're going to try to open up schools
and we're going to try to move through
this political
battlefield and president biden saying
kids have to go back to class
we can and we must open schools this
fall full time
it's better for our children's mental
and emotional well-being
and we can't afford another year out of
the classroom
every school should be open and we're
giving them the tools to be able to do
so safely
so dana the teachers union that randy
white guernin
represents it has come out against
mandatory vaccinations
and she's been saying for a long time
going back and forth on
school reopenings she claims they want
to go back but it doesn't seem like they
do
it was pretty i'm sure it's very
shocking for parents to hear
that they're going to try to reopen
schools
of which some of them start next monday
like in the south that's
one of the they start on august 9th so
there has never been a stronger moment
for school choice advocates to press
their advantage but unfortunately that's
like
we have an urgent situation i think
president biden recognizes it
he is soft-spoken in his language and
his tone but i hope that behind the
scenes they
are applying some pressure to make sure
that those schools are open one thing
that bothers me about what she said
about this entire thing is that
they said that delta was just so
surprising well no
actually were you paying attention to
what happened in india did you not
read the front page of the new york
times
every single day you could see all these
poor people asking for begging for
oxygen and figuring out a way to deal
with unfortunately the the dead
they were having to burn them in the
streets and this was not
this should not have been a surprise in
any way the administration had a
goal set to get seventy percent vaccine
at least one shot by
uh july 1st they missed it but
we're having an uptick right now of the
vaccines there is no reason
that schools should not be open parents
have got to get back to work
and already you see some companies
saying they were going to bring
people back to work in september i think
google it was today that said actually
and apple said we're going to push that
to october well what does that do to
your plants
if you're a family you have to plan
ahead especially if you're a single
parent
you've got to figure out how how am i
going to get my kids taken care of
there's
there's so much riding on this the
schools have to actually have to have to
open
my last point on this mckinsey put out a
study showing
how much children lost in this last year
and a half of remote learning including
about sixty thousand dollars as of now
that they will lose over their lifetime
in terms of earnings
because of the loss of that type of
education what does that compound to
we cannot sentence these kids to another
year of remote learning
geraldo what is the excuse for the
teachers unions they asked and demanded
to get put in front of the vaccine line
they were accommodated they still
refused to go back to school the cdc
comes out
this week and says that kids under 12
must be masked for
all hours of the day despite all the
signs for a year now showing that kids
are not the problem
and that they shouldn't be wearing masks
and now you're seeing her say
well maybe we'll try to get back and
using every excuse in the book
to continue to extort taxpayers for more
money
well you use the expression excuse i i
believe you're right
i believe that it is an excuse
that the all-powerful teachers union
they it made me sick to my stomach when
i heard randy weingarten
because as as a parent of a school
child uh admittedly she's a sophomore in
high school now but
and and i have resources but to
to hear the teachers union suggest that
once again on my grandchildren in public
school
once again that they're not going to go
to school that all the the
all that we've been through 16 months
and everything all these promises and
everything else and now they're not
going to go to school
she let that that it was like the threat
of an atomic bomb it was so
severe and so profound that i'm sure
that every
school parent out there that heard that
had the same kind of
that i had this is a very very serious
threat
from a very very powerful if not an
all-powerful
union chief that can determine the fate
of the public school parents
yeah and greg who does this this hurt we
know now right minority students
students who are
their moms are single and trying to work
minimum wage jobs
we know that special needs kids need to
be in school
and yet even the president won't come
out and have the courage to tell these
people to get back to work
i'm not so sure anymore i wonder if this
is the
golden opportunity to fix education that
we know that it's broken
we know the teachers union sucks we know
that uh
i'll get into the suicide rates in a
minute but i
i this isn't about the kids this is
about the teachers
there's something going on here that
that like they're not saying out loud
and it has to do with the number of the
teachers who are really vaccinated
is that what it is i don't know i mean i
mean why i mean
what else could it be that that has to
be she
is scared of telling her the teachers
that they got to go back because she
knows half of them maybe aren't
vaccinated
if this was indeed maggot country these
teachers would be crucified
so i think what we know is they're not
maga country
and she is not going to force them so
there's something there's something
that's not being said that's my theory
uh i don't know if about you when you
said our kids losing something
not if we focus on improving remote
learning i flipped on this issue i
thought kids should be back in school
and then i saw the suicide rates
jump every single time girls returned to
school
what by who who's killing themselves uh
young girls between like 12 and seven
because they have to go to school you
know when they get back into class and
then it drops when that when
and this has been looked at for decades
in um
summer and christmas vacation the
suicide rates always drop
and then when it did when it's a pattern
when they get back to school it goes up
and it's so what we're seeing with the
pandemic is it's telling us something we
already knew
our education system is broken and
there's something inherently toxic about
it
as we also learn how important family is
because as these girls and boys are at
home
suicide rates go down but then once they
get into school and are sh
and are shaped and tortured by peer
pressure who has the best clothes who's
on instagram
the stuff changes and i just feel like
the teachers union might be providing a
final way out
the number one issue in america is
education it's not crime because if you
fix
education you're gonna fix crime right
good education means no crime
and i always go back to the the peloton
option you marry at-home technology
with charismatic instructors you
nationalize the classes
and you pay them exorbitant money as
though they're celebrities
you don't need teachers unions anymore
you got the greatest teachers in the
world you got your kids at home
you focus on the remote learning you you
say screw you teachers union
and screw the public schools thank you
professor gutfeld
jesse you're dreaming i know i am you're
dreaming because i do not want to be
home with jesse jr all day
my kids are in private school and
they're school choices
there we need school choice i would say
it's a money play they already squeezed
what 100 billion out of the taxpayers
they're looking for a little more greg's
right a lot of these hot spots and these
unvaccinated spots are in big cities
that's where the teachers unions operate
i think they're not being honest about
vaccination rates
and i think honestly a lot of them liked
working from home they don't want to be
crowded into these school
classrooms with all these nasty kids
yelling at them
the other thing is parents are so angry
over crt
right now to even flirt with the concept
that they're going to be
stuck home doing remote learning you put
that on top of that that's going to
people are going to go crazy
if my kids were in a school that was
threatened like this
i would have to storm into a school
board meeting would you want someone
like me
storming into this what's happening it's
happening absolutely not i want to say
something about washington d.c
there is there was one cove death
in july in washington d.c and i'm
looking at peter ducey and ducey's got a
mask on
i want to see ducey's face and it's
sending but more importantly it's
sending the wrong message to the country
everyone's watching people in in
washington
a city of seven hundred thousand with
one coveted death
in july and we're all massed up now that
is crazy hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else